and happening tomorrow in henderson the  city is teaming up with babies bounty in  las vegas to provide diapers and wipes  as part of their diaper bank program  the event runs from 10 a.m until two in  the afternoon  families can pick up enough diapers and  wipes to last about a month  our clients that we've previously  assisted with our baby bundling program  were calling and saying listen  i'm on my last diaper i don't have any i  don't have any other resources for the  next diaper change so far in 2020 we  we distributed we helped 7 500 families  distributed over 300 000 diapers  and over a million wipes  if you haven't bought diapers lately  they're expensive so here are the  details again the drive will be at the  valley view rec center again that's in  henderson  from 10 to two you can sign up on their  website we do have a link on ours in  order to get you there